for the first time since 1982 Parliament  went through four rounds of votes for  electing its new president conservative  Italian Antonio Tajani 15,000 asylum  seekers are currently stranded on the  Greek islands battling a cold front with  freezing temperatures lawmakers urged  for emergency aid on their behalf that's  how many members of parliament voted in  favor of a set of European social rights  so it boosts labor protection in a  digital economy 11 countries are on the  blacklist for allowing money laundering  and terrorist financing MEP also want to  add states that enable tax crimes to the  list freight transport within the EU  will have increased by seventy percent  by 2050 bad news for the environment  Parliament calls for cargo to favor a  combination of trains ships and trucks  to reduce pollution  [Music]